CALLED ME A COPPELSTANDING IS
THAT YCHING THISVEISUSLY DT YOUD
FOR A LONG CUH
U?
Y'SE DISTRTWANE
REESTIMONYDOCUMENTATIONISRN BRAC
FACT SUSPECT THAT HE YOU'RE
CATK S O AD NONSENSE WITH THE
KNOWALHE INS OF MAR-LAICAL GG AY
ACHINGUT HOWHEIN BAD THIS
COUN
YE THAT WASNG THATOU
CAN SBOUT NOW THAT TNT IS PU COD
TR IS NOT THE MISDEMEANOR
BUSINESS FRA THAT
THAT BNTSEEMS
PR SOLID. IT'S THE QUEIO
OFTH O THISO
BECOME, WHICH
BUSINESS FRAUDAN
ONE TO OTHRI
ARNOTPE WHATCRES BE, THE ARGUMET
HAVE SOMETHING TO
DO.M W THEPAIGN
ELECTIONCIER
OR NOT THESE WEREPAIGN
SU  THAT
VI THE NATIO ITS PARENT COY
SOINTEREINE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THI ABOUT
WHETHER ORAL
WIFE AND MY FAMILY, BUT TWI ISNM
THIS DOC CITED.NT
INCDOUGAL,  KAREN
MACDLUBLIC HE BECAUSE HE WAS
COD ABOUT THE EFFEC
COANDIDACY.OF THE
STATEMENT ANDAGAIN ON PAGE
SIX ON THE SRM. TRUMP INSTRUCTED
ALTOGETHERAUHA NOT MATTER IF THR
BRAGG BASEDN  COMMENTSOUR TNDE C
AMO WILLPROVIDINGBOUT HIDING TSR
CORROBORATE ALL THE
TIONS O THE STATEMENTS
EV. DIDT  OURESHE GRAOUR V
THISSK, MUCH
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
INFORMN, NOT
BECAUSE HE CUT
ITMLOGIZE. I
?  TESTIMONY THAT I
PROVIDEDD JURY. BNT O IN THIS DD
RE YOU T TO PROVIDE THEY EVIDEHA
RELIEDAND HUSN THE
DRAFTING OF THIS C
OLTS
THAT TOOK P INCLUDING IN
2017.  WERE STILL IN
TMPOU FUST RE PHE BEGAN TO SOUR
BETWN YOU AND DD TRUMP. IT
WAS AROUND OF T
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.E THETAUM,E
NT TO DOT MEAN,
AGAINSTE THAT HE FINDS TOMAKEHEE
BEL OF HIM T ITS WHETHER IT'S IN
BRAGG WHETHER IT'E
S THE PROSECS
S TO BE A THREATO  WHATEVER MDBT
ABOUT YOU DISCUINES HIS NEED TO0
IE
OVAL OFFICE O W DON
ERE HA
TH OL
HOUSE?GAIN
WE'RE GOING INTO CONVERSATIONSRM
THE SORT
OFNG EXPECT.
TO TAKE PLACE INSE OF THOFFICEHO
AVE HAPPENED NEAR
CONCERNED ALSO TRUE THAT THIS
OR IS OU WELCOMELYSON. AND IWELN
'SNOWSE LINES
AT, UH
KN, HAS PUT OUT FOR MANY
PEOPLEO
WHAT T
CONTINHENCE, WHICH IS
THE THA PDE T, WHICH WAS DONE AE
J. TRUMP A I COOR
KEOMENT A Y W MY B WAS A.  ABOUE
WH, THE UENSWAS0. AND IFT'LIE, A
MONEY ONE.OF THE THINGS BYL
INTERESTING ABO THE STORMY
NI. I'M
TALKING ABO HER INORMY ONOF INOZ
TRUMP. THIS IS OBVIOUSLY YEARS
RE HE ANCE
RUINENFACTF  WAS A PUBLIY IT
? WA JCAUSE
PEERNOTICEIRST TE OF IN TOUCH M
STYL,  NOT. I'MT REIFIC DOCUMENE
ODEOMETHIREDORASTORMYALD
I'M NORERTICLEC D COM TT WASAKEN
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WHATD  OF T
TODAYWHAT DID WHAT DID YOU
THINK OFAREN
INTIO THESE FACTS TO LIGHT A ISK
CASE AGAIN TEF,
NALD JUM WAS MER TO PROVIDE INFG
BACK TO WITH GEORGTETY BELONGST
A CRIME. ANDIMES
WERE RELEVANT ENOUGH TISTRICT TT
THIS ISTHAIT. UM OR A.
PROVIDERMATIOCIA
AT THE APPROPRIATEIM IN
COURT TODAY. TRUMP ATTORNEY T, S
IAL MEDIA, WHKNOWE HED TO BE BEE
IN TERMS OF THE HE'SIVIDUALS, IG
CALLING DISICAN, HE
BY CITING YOUR PODCASTSYO INTERS
ACOLYTES TO ATTACK MWHATEVER PLS
I WEAK POWERLL CONTINUE TONSPARE
MIISAS WA SO GOOD ATSBODY ELSE'E
HAEL COHEN WROTE BOOK. THEREFOR
TO TURN AROUNDSAY, THEHING AGAE
, FAMILY ON. TH
NOT THE WAM WORKS ANDY MR BHE KW
AT W
, JUSTING BEEN IN TD FOR SO L WR
S
HE CALLS HIM A LUNATIC WHEN HE
CALLS THEEY
ALVIN BRAGG. UM AN ANIMAL.
HE CRITICIZESRAGGGEORGE SOROSWHD
E HTERJUSTNG PUGILISTIC
ATTAC? OR DOES HEACTUAL WANT? L
HATE TO SAY COBOYOS
TRYINGHAT HE'S
REAND NKS BYAC
NOBODY IS ABLE TO TELL HIMFF BED
GOG  RUN THE
THE WAY HE WANTS, IC THIS OF
NOW R
, BECAUSE  LEG
WANTS TO TAKE HIM ONAUOU AN OFT
ADCE AT THE END OF THE DAY
ONE LAST QUESTION MICHA,U
ISON TRUMPD  LOT
OF HIS SUPPORTERS IN RE
BEINGO WAS AERY WEALTHY
PROGRESSIVE WHO FUNDS A
PROGRESSIVE PROSECU
ON TIBTHE
SPECTRUM. GEOROR IS A HOLOCAUST
AND
CRITICIZE GEORGE NOT HAPPE
SAYINGRITICIZING GEORG. IT
ISN'T. BUT YOU THINK THE WAYAT .
YOU? DO YOU TH DOING
IT'S AN ANTIEASON?
MITIC TROPE, AND I THI
HETIO LOOK SEEN DONALD THINGSIKM
FOR
S ORO SOME WHO TN, THIS ISTEHAVS
NO AGAINS WHY HE'S HAVING
TIM IN S GETTINGPEHEEFANYO HE N
THIS CASET
. HE KNOWSERE'S THEEO. THNI WILE
DOWN SOON BOTH AC CASESO ALVIN ?
WHAT'S THE DIFFENC A SUDDEN? WED
AND 4TH.N'